Es ist ein bisschen wie ein Rausch.
Es ist eine grosse Euphorie.
Du freust dich einfach darüber,
dass du ein so tolles Schnäppchen
gemacht hast.
Manchmal
fühle ich mich auch schuldig,
dass ich zu dieser Konsum-
gesellschaft auch etwas beitrage.
Aber grösstenteils
sind es positive Gefühle.
Ich bin Rafi, 23-jährig und
leidenschaftlicher Schnäppchenjäger.
Mit den Schnäppchen ...
Das ist das Lustige:
Ich bin per Zufall
auf preispirat.ch darauf gestossen.
Das war vor eineinhalb Jahren.
Ich sah:
Es gab eine Rabattaktion bei Hiltl -
von 99 %.
Ich reservierte gleich im Hiltl.
Dann ging ich dort
mit fünf Kollegen essen.
Und es war wirklich so:
Es gab wirklich 99 % Rabatt.
Ich war nicht von Anfang an
Feuer und Flamme dafür,
überhaupt nicht,
aber mit der Zeit merkte ich schon,
dass es gar nicht so falsch ist,
dass man das Maximum
herausholen will.
Denn eben: Sonst ist es ja
wie verschenktes Geld.
Da kam ich immer mehr hinein.
Ich suche Schnäppchen
v.a. auf toppreise.ch,
dann natürlich die Tagesangebote
von Digitec usw.
Dann gibt es noch Gutscheine,
z.B. in den Zeitungen.
Ich bekomme noch Broschüren
nach Hause geliefert.
Da sehe ich auch nach,
ob es ein gutes Angebot gibt.
Pro Tag verbringe ich
etwa zwei Stunden damit,
nach Deals zu suchen.
Und ich würde sagen,
ich gucke jede Stunde auf Preispirat
oder auf Toppreise nach,
ob es dort schon etwas Neues gibt.
Dort gibt es auch so eine Übersicht,
bei der man
die stärksten Preissenkungen sieht.
Ich schaue jeweils nach, ob sich in
der letzten Stunde was geändert hat.
Mein Interesse,
dass ich solche Deals einschicke
und auf Preispirat aktiv bin,
rührt daher, dass ich sparen möchte,
denn ich bin Student.
Ich brauche das Geld.
Ein weiterer Grund ist,
dass ich mir Sachen leisten kann,
die ich mir nie
hätte leisten können -
oder zumindest nicht
in einem solchen Ausmass.
Andererseits aber auch, dass man
den Leuten verklickern will,
dass wir z.T.
ziemlich verarscht werden
und dass man das nicht einfach
so hinnehmen und akzeptieren sollte.
Bei sehr guten Schnäppchen
schlage ich manchmal
wirklich sehr impulsiv zu.
Das ist mit einer bestimmten Freude
verbunden.
Dann, im Nachhinein,
kommt ein Schuldgefühl,
wenn ich merke, dass ich es
eigentlich gar nicht brauche.
Wirklich sehr gute Angebote
sind natürlich zeitlich befristet
oder in der Stückzahl limitiert.
Deswegen
muss man ziemlich schnell zuschlagen
und nicht lange überlegen, ob man
das wirklich braucht oder nicht.
Denn wenn man es braucht
und es nicht gekauft hat,
fühlt man sich noch blöder, als wenn
man es kauft und nicht braucht.
Man kann es immer zu
einem guten Preis weiterverkaufen.
Beim E-Bike, das ich gekauft habe,
konnte ich durch die Kumulation
von mehreren Gutscheincodes
den Preis drücken.
Ich habe im Onlineshop
etwa 23 Gutscheine
miteinander kombiniert.
Ziemlich oft sind die Gutscheine
auch numerisch ...
... nacheinander aufgeteilt.
Beim E-Bike z.B. war es so,
dass die letzten fünf Ziffern
eigentlich den Gutschein ausmachten.
Wenn man diese abändert ...
... kommt man vielleicht
auf einen Gutscheincode.
Dann kam ich am Schluss
auf etwa 10 % ...
... Einkauf.
Und ... ähm ...
Was bei solchen Preis- oder
Gutscheinfeldern auch wichtig ist,
ist, dass man
eine Filialabholung auswählt,
alles aber schon im Onlineshop
bezahlt.
Meinen Fernseher
habe ich bei melectronics gekauft.
Ich erkannte gleich, dass es ein
sehr gutes Angebot werden könnte,
wenn man die richtigen Gutscheine
miteinander kombiniert.
Da bekam man
schon 20-fache Cumulus-Punkte.
Ich konnte noch
einen zehnfachen generieren,
weil ich Famigros-Mitglied bin.
Ich musste einfach
ein Kind hinzufügen,
bei dem ich den Geburtstag
richtig geplant habe.
Nach etwa fünf Tagen
kam der Gutscheincode dann.
Das waren dann schon mal 30 %.
Dann hatte ich noch
einen elffachen Gutscheincode
von der Genossenschaft Zürich.
Und dann nochmals 5 %,
weil ich in der Migros
einen Grosseinkauf machte,
und nochmals zweifach.
So kam ich auf insgesamt 48 %.
Dann bekam ich den Fernseher
statt für 1'800 Fr.
irgendwie für 980 Fr.
Und Katzenfutter
habe ich auch im Wert von ...
... 360 Fr. gekauft.
Effektiv
habe ich 180 Fr. ausgegeben.
Wenn sich die Händler
nichts dabei überlegen
und einfach so eine einfache
Gutscheingenerierung machen,
sind sie eigentlich selber schuld,
wenn die Leute dahinterkommen
und wissen:
"Aha, es sind nur die letzten
fünf Zahlen, die man ändern muss."
Dann sollen sie
personalisierte Gutscheine einführen
oder mit Buchstaben und Zahlen,
die viel schwieriger
herauszufinden sind.
In meinen Augen
ist das kein Beschiss.
Das ist einfach die Ignoranz
dieser Händler,
die man ausnutzen darf.
Unser Verlangen nach Konsum
ist sicher
von den Möglichkeiten beeinflusst,
die wir haben.
In erster Linie ist es das Geld.
Und wir werden überall
mit Werbung konfrontiert.
Das stachelt uns dazu an,
Sachen einzukaufen.
Und dann natürlich
auch gewissermassen,
dass man sich sozusagen profiliert,
dass man sich zeigt,
dass man mit bestimmten Produkten
angibt.
Es ist ein bisschen wie
ein Teufelskreis, würde ich sagen,
denn wenn der eine etwas hat,
sieht es der andere und sagt:
"Cool, das will ich auch haben!"
Ich stehe der Konsumgesellschaft
eher kritisch gegenüber,
wobei ich mich auch als Opfer
dieser Konsumgesellschaft sehe.
Ich versuche, meinen Konsum
auf einem möglichst tiefen Minimum
zu halten.
Natürlich
schaffe ich das nicht immer.
Ich kann auch nicht behaupten,
dass ich ein mega Ökofreak wäre,
denn ich habe einen Fernseher,
ein Smartphone - alles Mögliche.
Das ist halt der Luxus,
den wir haben und haben dürfen.
Aber es ist gleichermassen
auch unser Fluch,
dass wir uns nie mit dem
zufriedengeben, was wir haben,
und immer das Neuere und Beste
wollen.
Ich persönlich
bin kein Fan von Black Friday,
wenn ich ehrlich sein soll.
Da heisst es wieder:
"Kauft dies! Kauft jenes!"
"Kauft es, weil es günstig ist,
und nicht, weil ihr es braucht!"
Das finde ich natürlich
nicht so gut.
Andererseits finde ich es gut,
dass dadurch ein Wettkampf
zwischen den Händlern entsteht
und dass Preise unterboten werden,
die man nicht
für möglich gehalten hätte,
Preise, die schon fast gestört sind.
Von daher
hat es sicher seinen Nutzen,
aber es hat auch seine Nachteile.
Die meisten Kritikpunkte,
die ich in den Zeitungen lese,
sind Unglaube.
Sie sagen:
"Das ist doch gar nicht so!"
Und: "Ihr kauft Sachen,
die ihr gar nicht braucht."
Und ein weiterer Kritikpunkt
ist derjenige
mit der Konsumwegwerfgesellschaft.
Dem stimme ich auch zu.
Aber ich würde fast behaupten,
dass Leute wie ich,
die so viele Schnäppchen machen,
diese Sachen viel mehr wertschätzen
als Leute,
die sich das einfach spontan kaufen
und sich dabei nicht viel überlegen.
Wir planen das auch immer schön
und überlegen uns:
"Wann könnte ich das gebrauchen?"
"In welchem Zeitraum
sollte ich das gekauft haben?"
Es ist mir sicher wichtig,
wie mich andere Personen auffassen.
Es ist mir aber v.a. auch wichtig,
dass sie mich nicht
als Geizkragen betrachten,
weil ich einfach sparen will,
das auf jeden Fall,
sondern dass sie mich
einfach eher als ...
... geldbewussten,
finanzbewussten Menschen sehen.
Hey!
- Ciao!
Alles klar?
- Geht's dir gut?
Und euch?
- Auch.
Meine Kollegen
haben ziemlich überrascht reagiert -
oder reagieren ziemlich überrascht -
auf meine Schnäppchenleidenschaft.
Sie finden sie
auch ein bisschen freaky, aber ...
Sie schreiben mich nicht ab.
Sie ziehen ja auch
einen Vorteil daraus,
wenn sie mal etwas brauchen.
Aber es ist sicher
nicht etwas Normales.
Ja, genau!
Ich wünschte mir, dass die Händler
gar keine Gutscheincodes einführen
und die Sachen von Anfang an
reduziert anbieten würden.
Dann müsste ich die Codes nicht
jedes Mal scannen und mir überlegen:
"Habe ich den und den gescannt?"
Das ist viel zu aufwendig
und zu undurchsichtig für die User.
Es sind ein paar Auserwählte,
die wissen,
dass es den Gutscheincode gibt.
Ich finde das schlecht.
Das sollte für jedermann
zugänglich sein.
Insgesamt würde ich sagen,
dass ich von dieser Schnäppchenjagd
auf jeden Fall profitiert habe.
Ich habe schon viele gute Deals
gemacht.
Es gab sicher auch schon Tage, an
denen ich eher weniger profitierte,
aber wenn man
alles zusammen ansieht,
habe ich sicher einen
sehr grossen Mehrwert bekommen.
Sonst würde ich es
auch nicht weitermachen,
wenn es anders gewesen wäre.